I had exposure to mathematics at a very early
age.
My father is a mathematician, so I was always
interested in what my father was doing.
In school I was naturally drawn by mathematics
and physics.
My PhD was in the physics department, but it was really a PhD in mathematics.
I was always attracted to the fact that the
statements in mathematics are permanent.
The field I'm in is essentially at the interface
between probability theory and mathematical
analysis or theory of partial differential
equations.
And one of the big questions in the field
is this question of universality which says
that many systems exhibit very similar, essentially
identical, large scale behavior although the
microscopic descriptions are very, very different.
There are some situations where this large-scale
behavior is not described by a Gaussian object,
and these are extremely poorly understood.
I was always interested in the physics of
sound — understanding what sounds are, what
they look like or what they're made of.
So there is a very indirect connection between
the analysis of sound and the two books that
I've been developing for analyzing these posed
equations, which is that to some extent both
of them rely on wavelet analysis.
So I was walking to my office when I suddenly
realized that wavelet analysis would give
me a tool that allows me to go from one-dimensional
systems to higher-dimensional systems, and
then also make the analysis that I'd previously
done on one-dimensional systems more robust.
You can really get an idea anywhere, at any
moment.
It doesn't have to be in the office.
It really helps to kind of do something completely
different — listen to music, do some cooking
— but still keep it at the back of your
mind.
I think it's really important to do genuinely
curiosity-driven type of mathematics.
I think it's only by being genuinely curious
about the problem and genuinely interested
in the problem that you will be able to keep
it in your head for sufficiently long time
or sort of think about it in a sufficiently
focused way to actually make some real progress.